jack harlow shows his support for lil
nas x at the bet awards
after culture's biggest night failed to
nominate the rapper this year
[Music]
the two singers collaborated on last
year's industry baby
and now jack dons a t-shirt featuring
his brother in music
seemingly a response to little naz's
criticism of the awards
bt
in a statement to e.t bt said they love
lona's x and noted his lack of
nominations were the result of the
voting body choosing other artists to
honor
the network also made it known that it
advocates for inclusion and diversity
but lonaz is pushing for more in light
of the so-called snubs i think we have a
long way to go in some places but i feel
like the world is definitely trying his
best to change in many ways i'll say
that
and jack wasn't little naza's only
supporter on culture's biggest night
more stars had something to say about
the situation on the red carpet it's
been a little controversy with little
nas what do you think about that because
he's very upset he didn't get nominated
you know i don't think he's wrong about
um the way that black
you know
sexuality is embraced within the
community or not in the lack of
embracing um he's not wrong do i agree
with his approach
no
but i understand that's how he
rose to popularity is through shock
value i love lenore x baby that song was
hidden okay i work for b b-e-t but when
you ain't when you when it's good it's
good
[Music]
you